so put simply without a solid foundation
in maths our children risk being left
behind shot out of careers they aspire
to and the lives that they want to lead
now in the last decade or so we've gone
up 10 places in the international league
tables and math has become the most
popular of all a levels
but it's still the case that the UK is
one of the least numerous countries in
the developed World more than 8 million
adults have numeracy skills below those
expected of a nine-year-old
and around a third of our young people
don't pass math GCSE
now it's not that we're not just good
enough at maths there's a cultural issue
here too
I'll be honest when my two young
daughters first heard me talk about them
doing more maths they weren't too
excited
and that's just it
we make jokes about not being able to do
maths it's socially acceptable we say
things like oh maths I can't do that
it's not for me and everyone laughs but
we'd never make a joke like that about
not being able to read
so we've got to change this anti-maths
mindset we've got to start prizing
numeracy for what it is a key skill
every bit as essential as reading
so my campaign to transform our national
approach to maths is not some nice to
have
it's about changing how we value maths
in our country and changing the way our
education system works to deliver it so
that all our children get these vital
skills for life
now parents and teachers listening to
this will want to know what that means
for our children today so let me tell
you
we're in the process of making maths
more accessible building our children's
confidence so that they don't fear maths
we're creating more sector specific
content that can excite young people
about the relevance of Maths for the
careers that they aspire to
to help teachers bring math to life in
the classroom from building sets for
school plays to calculating the angles
of free kicks or the speed of a Formula
One car
we're extending our math hubs unique
Partnerships of expert schools that
support math teaching and we're
strengthening maths in primary schools
including with a new fully funded
professional qualification for those
that are teaching it
but we also need to address a very
specific problem that's causing us to
fall behind the rest of the world
we're one of the few developed countries
where young people don't routinely study
some form of maths up to the age of 18.
they do it in Australia Canada France
Germany Finland Japan Norway and America
why should we accept any less for our
children of course we shouldn't
that's why I set out in January that
we're going to change the way our system
works so that everyone in our country
will study some form of maths all the
way to 18.
but let me be absolutely clear I am not
saying that the answer is a level Maths
for everyone
but we do need to work out the maths our
young people should study so we're going
to look at what 16 to 18 year olds
around the world are learning and we're
going to listen to employers
and ask them what they say the math
skills are that they need
and that's why today am I pointing a new
expert group
who will help us identify the core math
content that our 16 to 18 year olds need
and whether we need a new specific
qualification to support that
but to repeat that will not be a level
Maths for all